E aí
[Música]
é muito bom dia
como advogada no ramo do direito à
família há cerca de 25 anos tenho
constatado uma uma realidade que não é
conhecida de todos mas que tem um forte
impacto na sociedade Portuguesa e o
facto de Portugal por um durante os
últimos dez anos se ter mantido no topo
do ranking dos divórcios a nível europeu
e numa posição destacava a nível Mundial
para que saibam entre 2010 e
2019 a taxa de divórcio em Portugal
oscilou entre os 60 e os setenta por
cento ou seja são números Avassaladores
e que permitem que nós todos conhecemos
alguém que tenha vivenciado ao que
esteja a vivenciar esta realidade
e a
recentemente o Quando eu digo
recentemente é eu vejo se isto funcionar
recentemente
saíram os números oficiais relativos a
2020 contusão eu entendo que estes
números tem que ter uma leitura muito
cuidada porque a durante o ano 2020 as
conservatórias e os tribunais estiveram
encerrados ou com seus serviços muito
limitados durante a maior parte do ano o
que impediu a concretização do muitos
divórcios e muitos me também muitos
casamentos mas se pegarmos aqui nos
números de 2019 que foi o ano em
diatamente antes da pandemia e dizendo
que nem foi dos anos piores dos últimos
dez constatamos que Portugal registou
20421 divórcios ou seja uma média diária
de 50 e 60
e
ora se isto é assim antes da pandemia
nós conseguimos imaginar os números que
aí vem e isto porque eu costumo dizer
então de brincadeira que nós advogados
de família costumamos ter os escritórios
seios pelo menos em duas ocasiões no ano
em setembro depois de duas ou três
semanas de férias a familiares de verão
e em janeiro depois dos dias festivos de
natal e ano novo hora que podem imaginar
se isto é assim ao fim de semanas e dias
de convivência familiar Imaginem o que
aí vem após um confinamento obrigatório
de largos meses e de famílias que ainda
hoje se mantém em tela é trabalho e a
realidade é que este confinamento exigiu
uma proximidade excessiva as famílias
que ficaram confinados a um determinado
espaço
muitas vezes Pais Filhos e às vezes a
voz
é sobre 24 horas o que implicou o
tensões familiares graves e exigiu
equilíbrios muito difíceis e o que é que
acarretou acarretou aquilo que hoje já
estamos a verificar que é o aumento dos
crimes de violência doméstica e
consequentemente o aumento dos
e o aumento dos divórcios hora para que
tenham noção da magnitude do impacto
desta realidade na sociedade portuguesa
eu chamava a vossa atenção
para um estudo desenvolvido a
recentemente pela Fundação Francisco
Manuel dos Santos que vem identificar o
divórcio como a principal causa de
entrada numa situação de pobreza isto
seguido a larga distância do desemprego
e da doença ou seja o colapso familiar é
muito mais gravoso do que uma situação e
o emprego vai e volta mas a sensação de
segurança à retaguarda inerente a uma
família é muito mais prejudicial a sua
ausência Claro hora há quem diga que
estes números são inevitáveis e que e
que se designe eu eu entendo que não
e dizem isso não normalmente porque
acham que Portugal é uma democracia
recente que o papel da mulher tem se
alterado radicalmente nos últimos anos
tudo verdade mas eu entendo que isso não
tem que ser necessariamente assim e
entendo que nós como cidadãos a nível
individual e o estado como regulador da
sociedade temos todos obrigação de
tentar reverter estes números nem que
seja para evitar as consequências
económicas e sociais que advém de uma
situação de divórcio e quais são essas
consequências aqui como vai fazer uma
this e entre o casal e os filhos quando
usar para o casal o divórcio em
normalmente visto como o fracasso de um
projeto de vida e que normalmente é
acompanhado por situações de depressão e
outras patologias do forno da Saúde
Mental
paralelamente Eu costumo dizer para a
grande maioria de famílias
existe aqui uma situação de
empobrecimento E empobrecimento por que
passam a existir duas casas duas contas
da água duas contas de luz filhos
repartidas e despesas e despesas
cobradas da mesma forma também se
constata que na fase indiretamente
pós-divórcio
existe uma coparentalidade conflituosa
com as consequências que todos podem
adivinhar a nível dos filhos eu
parece-me que a situação ainda é mais
gravosa e a rosa porque o divórcio está
identificado como a segunda
circunstância mais traumática na vida de
uma criança isto porque aumenta o risco
de diminuição da autoestima diminuição
do rendimento escolar
surgimento de medos e inseguranças
conflitos de lealdade parental e muitas
vezes e mais grave o afastamento de um
dos progenitores na sequência do
divórcio
hora
parece uma aqui que é a que fazer a aqui
é um certo enquadramento político e
social para vermos como é que chegamos
até aqui como se como se abram o
divórcio surgiu em Portugal em 1910 com
o aparecimento da República sendo que em
1940 foi assinado um protocolo a
concordata a Santa Sé e o estado
português que veio proibir o os
divórcios para os casamentos católicos
situação que só se vai a reverter com a
chegada do 25 de abril de
1974 contudo Na minha opinião nos
últimos anos o grande período de
inflação o grande ponto de inflexão foi
a chamada nova lei do divórcio de 2008
que veio trazer alterações Profundas
e nomeadamente e como corolário a
iluminação do conceito de culpa
ou seja esta nova lei revelou-se ser um
elemento facilitador do divórcio e um
elemento facilitador e que se traduziu
nos números que temos assistido nos
últimos anos
hora
constatado que está o enquadramento
político esse e as causas e as
consequências do divórcio
parece-me que e respeitando o tema desta
até toque morrom importa apontar saídas
e soluções linhas linhas orientadoras e
e aqui eu chamava a vossa atenção para
um estudo interessantíssimo da celebrado
a realizado recentemente em Inglaterra
pelo Center for social Justice e que
veio demonstrar que o o grande
o grande diferenciador social é o
casamento ou seja não é a raça não é o
gênero não é orientação sexual nem tão
pouco a classe social
quando analisamos as perspectivas de as
possibilidades de sucesso de uma criança
o facto a classe social a que pertence é
importante E se ela crescer Numa família
estável ainda que pobre tem mais
possibilidades de apanhar o chamado
elevador social num contexto de divórcio
tudo é mais complicado
Há quem diga quem conteste dizendo mas a
pobreza também é causa de instabilidade
familiar é certo mas o inverso também é
verdade é instabilidade familiar é causa
de pobreza e não podemos negar que as
competências emocionais e sociais de uma
criança são tão ou mais importantes
que as suas capacidades econômicas na
forma como se prepara para o futuro
acontece que aqui chegados temos um
obstáculo e que é o facto desta
necessária ideia de promoção da família
e do casamento é considerado um tema
reacionário e conservador
porque não se inclui nos temas
fracturantes das agendas mediáticas Ah e
por outro lado há quem diga que isto é o
estado intrometer-se na vida dos
cidadãos hora para mim estas estas
Críticas não colhem primeiro porque
quando falamos de família falamos de
família e no seu conceito mais alargado
onde cabem todos os casais
heterossexuais os casais homossexuais
cujo casamento já foi legalizado em 2010
e adoção em 2016 e mesmo as novas
famílias re compostas e quanto à crítica
da intromissão do Estado a mesma coisa
se nós olharmos para o que estão os
estados europeus a fazer
vemos Exatamente isso aliás eu assisto
sempre o exemplo da Dinamarca que
constatando a sua taxa de divórcio
inferior a nossa
entendeu que estava na altura de fazer
alguma coisa e então vai recentemente
implementar um conjunto de medidas para
travar esses números medidas como por
exemplo a implementação de um período de
reflexão
as mesas obrigatório para quem está a
solicitar o divórcio situação que
existiu em Portugal durante muitos anos
mas que já foi abolida há também há
muitos anos
e por exemplo a concessão de terapia
conjugal gratuita para os casais que
estão a equacionar o divórcio e um
conjunto de medidas e um conjunto de
medidas de cariz económico que visam
ajudar as famílias a nível financeiro
que o meu caso da licença parental de um
ano da da construção de creches públicas
gratuitas Claro para todas as crianças e
outras medidas de Apoio às famílias
Ou seja parece-me que está na hora de
descobrirmos as relações familiares
mantê-las saudáveis porque se alguma
coisa que aprendemos durante esta
pandemia foi que de repente podemos
ficar privados daquilo que não davam o
justo valor urge portanto repensar
aquilo que é essencial na vida muito
obrigado
E aí
[Música]